dominique pradalié secrétaire générale
du syndicat national des journalistes
dominique pradalié bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
l'article 24 qui a provoqué la polémique
a été réécrit pour ne plus faire
référence aux journalistes est-ce
suffisant selon vous non bien sûr que
non
l'article 24 a été réécrit pour la bonne
et simple raison qu'ils étaient trop
voyants consacre l attaque la liberté de
la presse
or quelle est la différence entre le
fait d'empêcher jeunesse de tournai est
le fait des cris en provocation à
l'identification
alors que l'on sait que les premiers qui
vont constater ou pensées ou soupçonner
qu'il peut y avoir provocations sont les
forces de l'ordre c'est à dire que sont
juges et parties
donc c'est pire qu'avant c'est pire
qu'avant parce que l'article 18 de la
loi séparatisme qui suit juste cette loi
sécurité le gall légal global pardon est
bien pire encore
dans ses attendus est ce que vous allez
faire appel de cette voie là de cette
décision est ce que vous prévoyez
justement de demander au conseil
constitutionnel de saisir cet article
alors de nombreuses contributions
extérieures vont moins bien évidemment
être dirigé vers le conseil
constitutionnel dès lors que 60
parlementaires vont
y avoir recours ce qui ne devrait pas
être chose très compliqué ni un ni très
tardive
simplement nous verrons si le conseil
constitutionnel consacre ou pas la
liberté de la presse la liberté
d'informer et d'être informé
sachant que pour le moment l'exécutif et
le législatif ont décidé de piétiner ses
libertés fondamentales de la patrie des
droits de l'homme
quels sont les autres points
d'achoppement autour de ce projet de loi
les points d'achoppement sont toujours
les mêmes à savoir le la destruction des
libertés fondamentales que sont celles
de manifester et à et le droit à la vie
privée par les drones invasif qui vont
avoir la possibilité de vous filmer à
tout et à n'importe quel instant puisque
le recours à ces drones est très floue
dans les termes de loi ce qui permettent
aux différents préfets d'agir comme ils
l'entendent aux différentes forces de
l'ordre d'enregistrer et puis dans
quelques temps de mettre la
reconnaissance faciale etc etc je veux
dire nous allons devenir le pays au
monde le plus policier si on ne réussit
pas à faire entendre raison au pouvoir
en place
faire entendre raison c'est possible de
plus en plus de citoyens sont en train
de se rendre compte que à travers la
pandémie sanitaires non seulement des
libertés leur sont provisoirement enlevé
notamment les libertés d'avoir accès à
l'art d'avoir accès à la musique d'avoir
accès à un certain nombre de deux le
liberté comme celle de voyager etc mais
que pendant qu'on leur enlève ses
libertés
on est en train de piétiner toutes les
autres et leur vin le réveil pas être
terrible
de mon point de vue nous faisons
beaucoup de pédagogie la corde il
a sion stop sécurité globale le snj et
d'autres nous ont énormément pédagogie
et petit à petit les citoyens sont en
train de se rendre compte de ce qui se
passe dans notre pays
merci beaucoup en tout cas devenir
l'allié d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général du syndicat national des
journalistes
merci